welcome to this blitz game against
international master hive trick 5 trick
Manuel Penn Yan Gomes okay let's see i
played with g 6 and so on can get to any
kind of opening if we actually get to a
modern defense okay mmhmm yeah let's
let's set up this hippopotamus stuff the
hippo it's not such a bad opening
especially if white has committed
himself to putting nights on f3 and c3
here wide legs a bit of the the bite in
the center with f4 and see form which
does not mean he is worse or anything
but this is a position that definitely
is playable for black some some forms of
the hippo I think are really a dubious
but this is something that black can
certainly certainly play it's not so
clear what white should do because every
important advance we form our
interesting b3 every pond advance if I
were d5 it will open up one of the
bishops so it's not so easy to find a
find a good plan for white without the
pawns advancing ok what am i doing now I
mean I have completed the the hippo
setup which is which is nice but what am
i doing now if I go see 5 he might
capture and ask some questions about my
pawn on d6 on my squares there hmm yeah
one cute maneuver is to put the Queen to
a 7 and go from there I can also play
with e 5 now that's also a possibility
or f5 all those pawn breaks are possible
f5 however looks a bit strange
maybe f5 takes Knight takes with
threatening Bishop f3 or maybe if you f
5ef and Bishop f3 is actually this is
possible it's not it's not totally
totally weird f5 if he does not if he's
not able to take I can play may play a
form that it is a risky move that's
enough no question okay very quickly
answered pretty surprised that he played
this so quickly when f5 wasn't totally
obvious choice okay no it's interesting
i canti can play look f3 the exchange
sacrifice is this is this something or
is this just just too fancy okay the
thing is I have to have to play I have
to play and one at one point maybe this
is nonsense but it is interesting the
bad thing is the stead term it took me
some time to to play it let's see they
had the idea is just to play on this
week squares what I don't have is the
rook is not in play this is this is a
problem the a eight look it definitely
wants to be in the game this is why I
went Queen edge for not for you gave aid
I don't what that's just this is a
strange move how do i do it can take a
95 or not let's start with that
the hive other air I'm surprised about
because I thought that this would be
quite nice with the night getting into
the attack here with the e5 square maybe
it's not not a big deal but ok wait I
want Queen on age 59 age for this is the
way to go of course you can take e 6 now
that sets maybe that sets a that's a
critical move but it's a risky move
teenage wife immediately was wasn't
possible due to Knight f6 so I had to to
do this prep move through gave aid and
now i'm also threatening Knight f3
directly
maybe I should have gone to e7 just
recovering this pawn but I don't know ok
i am have spent ahead spent quite some
time earlier so when it's um it was good
to catch up a little bit on the clock
which i managed yeah that's not easy to
play for what I mean night h4 is also
very serious smooth
yeah I really don't don't see what you
should do now that some it seems
difficult to play this position
now that that's a very sharp hob tribe
with Knight f6 coming okay but I'm
really meeting him right I mean ok I
have to play that anyway so it was a bit
bit idiotic to spend time on it ok so
this moves what is he threatening is he
threatening he's threatening to take
everything is that night h4 is almost a
maid as his Bishop takes a phone Bishop
takes before actually is interesting if
he takes on f8 we can you can promote to
enlight but I will win quite some
materia there okay if I go rookie it is
ok let's take here I have to do that
anyway I guess you cannot cannot promote
to pin to a queen because of made on g2
King f1 is 93 with a mate so he has to
take rook takes e4 and then I'm taking
on on the one with check that looks
really really bad
okay I look before Queen D 1 check now
and then I just move the rock and
probably check
kingi one runs in 29 th fri that's
completely completely over so rookie 8
and that's it right Queen have six is
not threatening anything a guy from 97
yeah that that's a jam I'm winning f2 or
whatever yes he doesn't even have a
squad for the wrong side yeah I don't
know this was an interesting exchange
sacrifice that I cannot really assess
properly now but it was definitely an
interesting way to play I was a bit
surprised that after f5 he played this
route 81 so so quickly maybe it is just
the best move but still was the Ted
surprising I don't have the clerk time
see I have to change some setup yeah if
he takes here I would if I thought I
would take here but the computer gives
this is better for wide so Kim
interesting okay I can I can of course
take with the night maybe this this one
but ok route 81 is certainly not a
mistake or anything yam and now look at
three that certainly debatable this move
little bit I thought it was interesting
I'm destroying a structure c4 I'm not
sure about this this c-45 plan because
it gives me the important e5 square I
really don't know it's difficult to
analyze this position properly here
Queen edge foyer well H flow is actually
the square for the night but I wanted to
wanted my my look into the game I don't
I didn't think I can do without the rook
and then this you know and now I really
I really get to e5 yeah here's the point
where the computer definitely gives
black enough compensation the computer I
mean sorry she wants to play a five or
Bishop g2 with about a pawn advantage
yeah which basically means okay here
you're an exchange down and you don't
have something concrete showing for it
possible it is not easy to play though
this d5 and 95 definitely gives me gives
me quite some compensation pretty sure
and see it starts to be be good for
Black Knight g7 as the best move now
that's interesting didn't think about
that oh okay this looks nice maybe but
it is not a good move because of a 7 ah
ok that sets tricky to see ya now now I
see the point d 7 is strong after night
eggs he's got this where am I going like
here and then he can counter sacrifice
for a great attack him this this this is
this is a bit much am I am ok that was
strong so my move here Queen age 5 has a
concrete problem this however is ok for
black or even good for black ok this is
this avoids this is tricks and the idea
is simply to take on e6 and jump to f4
when I get this in it's fantastic yeah
this is this is good but ok I didn't see
the tactics check until here here it is
very difficult for what computer says
equal but Wow necessary hard to play the
computer gives Queenie to as equal with
this this being the idea may I have very
nice compensation but probably it is
equal somehow and something that the
computer is giving is this kind of idea
ok and so II seven and now be shown
before winsome yeah this is winning now
take a check oh here i also had night h4
i am ok as I understand yeah King f1 I
can take you on on d1 yeah ok but this
is just this is just winning so there
was no no big need for for complicated
stuff and here he only just one check
which I can cover with the night and
then he has really no square for the
rookie he would lose the Roku to Queen
txf to check yeah interesting game i
hope you liked it thanks for watching